really somewhere in russia
the cyber safety of our local businesses
is always at risk by the time they found
out that money is long gone and there's
almost no way to get back businesses
rely on their networks data and the
internet to exist cyber criminals
exploit that from the mom and pop shop
to fortune 500 companies today it's
capital one last year it was marriott
the year before it was equifax the most
common thing that we're seeing with
businesses is what we call a business
email compromise which is where you have
you know it's also called a man in the
middle attack how it works the business
is about to start a transaction a
phishing email comes in saying wire
instructions have been updated some
companies fall for the hook now they've
wired you know we've seen cases with
five
200
thousand dollars and for some of these
small businesses that's enough to put
them out what business owners should do
is stop and phone first in every single
case where we've had somebody victimized
if they would have picked up the phone
and made that phone call prior to
sending the wire they wouldn't have lost
all the money according to the fbi the
cost of cyber crime in the u.s was three
and a half billion in 2019 with half of
all businesses the victim of a cyber
attack they never send any money you
know online or by mail or anything like
that unless it's somebody that you know
personally that you can trust companies
can better protect themselves by having
the encryption technology to cloak
customer credit card records supplier
networks and employee financial data an
easy fix improving password security
they compromise you know your bank
account and then you use the same
password on your email now they pretty
much own you multi-factor authentication
a must if you have that set up then now
at least there's an extra step that the
bad guy has to get through and check the
legitimacy of email correspondence by
hovering over the sender to see who it's
actually from the account might say
microsoft team well then when you click
on microsoft team it's like
dj5678 at aubtx 17. obviously that's a
scam companies skipping these important
steps present cyber criminals and
hackers an easy lock to pick and in some
cases a wide open door
you